I'm gonna have to add published author
to my business cards so if you follow my
social media stuff or if you pay
attention to the community tab on this
channel then you already know this but I
still wanted to do a video on it because
it's kind of crazy to me so I wrote a
book in and of itself actually not that
shocking I think there's a fair number
of you know youtubers of people who
dabble in various creative fields who
either are in the process are hoping to
or have in fact written a book the
difference is I mine's actually not
published which that's the part that's
insane to me
now it's self-published I actually spent
a couple years shopping this book around
and and not finding anyone who went with
it you know to publish it but I do want
to talk about it all the same so given
the nature of this particular book I let
my hair down
it's called skirting gender life and
lessons of a crossdresser now when I
have letting my hair down I've generally
pointed out that I have a fluid sense of
gender and I do identify it as gender
fluid I identified as a crossdresser for
the majority of my adult life and if
you've ever checked on my other channel
which is very wild right there then you
know you know a lot of that is geared as
advice for cross dressers or my own
experience as someone who was born male
and have I have times of my life when I
want to present much more feminine so
that's yeah this it is so weird for me
that I'm holding this in my hands this
is now available on Amazon both as an
e-book on the Kindle Store and
on demand you can get this in paperback
so it's gonna be available through some
other outlets as well hopefully soon
because this is the first time I've ever
self-published in anything so I didn't
go quite as smoothly as I had wanted I
had I had been aiming for a launch you
know everywhere at the same time but
some of the some of the preparatory work
for some of the other outlets I'm
setting up with ended up being a little
bit more complicated and the review
turnaround period for Amazon turned out
to be way shorter than I thought so
and also I think I was half expecting
them to come back and say we can't
publish it because you need to correct
this again this is formatted wrong or
whatever and then suddenly it was up
live on them on Amazon and I honestly I
kind of panicked wait what so yeah I
don't want to go like into too much
detail about it but it is it's a
combination of two things primarily it
is relaying of my own life experiences
from my earliest memories of dabbling in
any kind of gender variant behavior you
know through figuring myself out and
then there's a whole section on
practical advice you know everything
from general makeup tips things about
how to adjust your silhouette walking in
heels on all sorts of things like that
and then also sort of talking broader
topics like pronouns the difference
between you know gender identity and
sexual orientation and and then things
uh things along those lines so it's it's
all it's all compiled in that together
and it feels really good to get it out
like I said I had actually I've been
shopping this around for I think about
two years and I did get some interest I
got far enough that a few publishers
you know did ask for a more detailed
synopsis or some sample chapters
ultimately nobody wanted to move forward
on it and I hit a point where I'm like
well I feel like there are people who
could benefit from this either because
they themselves are going through some
sort of period of questioning and
they're looking for guidance or someone
who's been through something similar or
you know someone who knows somebody has
a loved one or a friend who you know has
gender non-conforming behavior and they
want to understand that person that they
care about a little bit better or maybe
just the idly curious I'd like to think
that you know even someone who doesn't
have a direct connection to this kind of
thing could still enjoy the book and I
also want to thank the people who
kick-started it because I the most
significant expense in self-publishing
is hiring an editor which you you need
to do and I think I think that's a
that's a a hurdle for a lot of would-be
self-published authors is that you think
well look this is good I know it's good
like no matter what it is no matter what
you're writing about whether it's
fiction that you needed editor you need
a professional editor who will look at
it and streamline it and make sure that
it works and the editor that that I
worked with her name's Sarah brown she
was phenomenal she really got what I was
going for and whenever she made a note
she you know she didn't just tell me
what to do she said well here's what I'm
thinking we should do instead and here's
why and it was an astounding help but
that was that was a that was a
significant expense because for for the
book you know again it's this thick it's
244 pages and it this ran me about a
grand to get professionally edited
because usually you're either paying by
the page or paying by the hour depending
on how they how they work it but that
that was about what I expected it to so
I I actually ran a Kickstarter to fund
being able to get a professional editor
and
so that was successful which was the
first big oh my god this really gonna
happen thing there are a lot of other
expenses involved in in getting a book
published that you don't necessarily
think about or that I didn't really get
much of a heads up on so you know
getting getting the cover design like
the picture I'd had for ages that is in
fact me the picture I'd had for ages I
knew I wanted to use it but like
actually getting this designed I needed
to bring somebody that actually Joel my
thumbnail guy designed that for me he
and he did great night I compensated him
for that if you want to sell it
somewhere other than Amazon you need to
you know you need needs to be searchable
with an ISBN number those you have to
pay for you want it to have a barcode
you got to pay for that it's there's a
lot of weird additional expenses that
you don't think of them there's a lot of
hassle involved but I'm really glad that
it's out there and it feels good to have
it out there and having now done that
not anytime soon because like I'm tired
I'm from from this experience in a good
way but having now gone through a
self-publishing experience it's put me
in a position where I might finally feel
comfortable to self publish a novel
because I I have actually written a few
I've written a bunch of stuff that is
basically done that I've been shopping
around for however many years has been
done I have have a finished novel I've
been shopping around for about three or
four years and I have short stories at
some of which are fairly recent some
always up and shopping around forever
it's really tough trying to find open
submission things and it takes forever
to hear back from them my about to act
play that I finished track Doge I did to
get a playwright if you don't have
with a theater troupe who will put up
basically I've just submit to contests
and those cost you to enter so I'm
having now actually gone through the
experience I might in the next couple
years be comfortable self-publishing one
of the novel's we'll see I it's it's
really weird having this done because I
that this is probably the first like
I've been thinking about this or been
working on this for years project that
I've finished probably in five four six
years I say the last time I had like a
real true what I would consider a
long-term project done was shooting the
the first batch of scripted shorts
actually for this channel you go way
back to the start of this channel it's
not me rambling at a camera they were
scripted shorts and those I've been
working on for a very long time and so
you know that was like the last time
that's something that was more than just
oh this will you know take me a few this
will take me like 20 minutes to shoot
and the half hour to edit and then I'll
put it up on the internet or you know a
week or two if it's more complicated but
something that I've been working on for
years this is the first time in a long
time that something that involved has
been finished and it feels kind of
amazing and I'm hoping because I am a
number of long-term stuff I've had in
various degrees of completion and at
least over the next couple of years I'm
gonna try and wrap some of these up I
want to try and get one of these
finished a year over the next couple of
years and I have a I think I know what I
want to try and get lined up and done
for next year I'm not gonna say what it
is not here because it's gonna be it's
gonna be involved it's gonna be a
paramount
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
pull it off but that's it's not the
novel I'm probably looking at a couple
of years down the road on the novel
because that I'm unlikely to do a
Kickstarter for because it because I did
feel with this book that it's something
that is relatively unique I mean it's
not it's not the only book out there
like that I know there are others out
there I've read some of them but it's
it's something that there isn't a huge
amount of product for so I felt like
that was something that I felt justified
doing a Kickstarter for cos like I feel
like there is there's a market that has
a need for this the novel that I wrote
it's it's a fantasy novel appropriate
age 12 and up there's a lot of the hoes
and I don't really feel justified
preemptively taking people's money to
put that out there so that that I want
to try it for myself but so that'll be a
few years off just to be able to save up
to do that but yeah the this has turned
into a general ramble about just sort of
completing long-term projects which is
it just feels real good and I feel like
in some ways if the this will be the
ultimate goal in terms of like building
this channel and my patreon support and
things like that is I would really like
to be able to work more on things that
are more involved and things that are
more long-term because that that's
what's the stuff that's really hard for
me to find the time to do because I mean
I work I work a full-time job I work 40
hours a week I'm cranking out a video
today I'm raising a kid and I'm managing
all that okay but you know finding time
to complete something that takes a long
time that's hard hey I mean for
superficial comparison it's a big part
of why I don't play video games much
anymore because most of the games that I
like
you know I was I was being into RPGs for
for a long time you know that that's a
lot of time to sink into that I don't
have 20 30 40 hours you know just
sinking in but you know I'll have these
huge gaps somebody time to get back to
it
I don't even remember what was going on
before so like what's the point and it
can feel like that would long-term
projects sometimes but completing one
feels good and I'll put links down in
the description for for the book for you
know the digital edition and the
physical edition I mean if you're just
to check it out this this video is not
intended as a sales pitch I just kind of
wanted to talk about it because is this
is a milestone for me like a significant
one kind of an in like not dissimilar to
hitting 10,000 subscribers and then
hitting 20 I this was something I worked
at and plugged away at and never thought
I was gonna actually see done I hoped
but I didn't think I would and yet here
we are and I can I can hold this friggin
thing in my hand I just ah man I and and
if you're curious there are there's
there are pictures inside it's all black
and white because the the cost bumps up
so much if you do color pictures but you
know so there's there's that as a sort
of visual aids and points of reference
and some of these pictures are ones that
you know work basically taken by me some
were taken by my friend said from from
upstate New York she also took the
picture that's on the cover we back when
we both lived in New York City
I'm just rambling at this point because
I'm really satisfied I'm really happy
that I got to see this through and
anyone who is interested in reading it
and finding out more about me and about
this side of my life specifically
obviously I mean this is this is not a
comprehensive autobiography this is
pretty specific to certain aspects of my
existence but anyone who's interested in
serious who wants to better understand
me and possibly other people like me
that's what I wrote it for so thanks for
indulging me guys's I just kind of
wanted to ramble on in a very very
satisfied way hope hopefully not too
like self-satisfied I don't mean to be
cocky but feel real good right now so
thanks so much for watching whatever
your thoughts on anything I said here
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of things to do there's
buttons and there's links and there's
the patreon and there's the links to the
book it's all gonna be down in the
description plus other things besides
check them out if you want to and until
next time folks just remember you are
the council I just run the meetings and
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]